the example of scheduling courses in
terms is really a special case of a
general problem that you can probably
see of scheduling a bunch of tasks or
jobs under constraints of which ones
have to be done before other ones which
is a topic that comes up actually in
lots of applications but you can see
applications in computer science where
you might have a complex calculation
pieces of which could be done in
parallel other parts had to be done in
order because later results depended on
the results of an earlier computation it
leads us to the general discussion of
parallel scheduling and we've already
worked out some theory of that really
just from the example namely if we look
at the minimum number of terms to
graduate this corresponds to the minimum
amount of number of stages or the
minimum amount of time that it takes to
process a bunch of tasks assuming that
you can do tasks in parallel and as many
in parallel as you need to that there's
no limit on the amount of parallelism
allowed in that case what we can say is
that the minimum parallel time for a
bunch of constrained tasks is simply the
maximum chain size in the constraint
graph we saw that example with the
course prerequisites where we had five
and in general this is the theorem
minimum parallel time is exactly equal
to maximum change size of four chains in
the graph that constrains the order in
which tasks can be completed now what
about the maximum term load well that
corresponds to the number of processors
you need to be a to be doing tasks in
parallel so for the course scheduling
example it means how many subjects can
you take in one term but if you were say
doing computations how many separate
CPUs would you need in order to be able
to fully utilize the parallelism do as
much in parallel as you possibly could
and a bound on the number of processors
that are needed for minimum time is
simply the Mac
some anti chain sighs which in the
example from the previous segment on
course scheduling it turns out there was
there were five courses you could take
in one term the second term and that was
in fact the maximum anti chain sighs so
that's an upper bound on the number of
processes that you need the number of
processors that you need to achieve
minimum time but in fact it's a course
upper bound because although the number
of processors needed to achieve minimum
parallel time is it most the maximum
anti chain size in fact in the previous
example it turns out you could get away
with three processes it was possible to
schedule the subjects so you only took
three courses a term and still finished
in minimum time so can you do better
than three subjects well there's a
trivial argument that says no you can't
because in that previous example we had
13 subjects to schedule the maximum
chain sized was five so what was going
to take at least five terms so that
means you have to distribute these 13
subjects among five terms there has to
be some term that has at least the
average number of subjects namely 13/5
so that means there has to be a terror a
term in which you're taking 13 / 25
subjects of course you round up because
it has to be an integer so the maximum
so the minimum number of terms to finish
and graduate finishing these 13 subjects
in five terms is three because 13/5
rounded up is three this is a general
phenomenon that applies in what we can
say is that if you have a dag with n
vertices and the maximum chain size is C
so that's how deep it can be at most and
the maximum anti chain size is a that's
the largest number of things that you
could ever possibly do in parallel then
clearly the total number of vertices is
C times a at most so the total number of
tasks that you can do where you are
going to finish in C steps using at most
a processors is bounded by C times a so
what that tells you is that you can't
both have the anti chain size and the
change size be too small because their
product has to be at least n that can be
rephrased as a little lemma that is
credited to a guy named Dilworth
Dilworth is actually famous for Dilworth
theorem of which this Dilworth lemma is
a special case but we don't need the
general theorem the Lord's lemma says
that if you have an N vertex dag then
for any number T it either has a chain
of size bigger than T or it has an anti
chain of size greater than or equal to n
overtake and we prove that this on the
previous slide the product of these two
things has to be at least n and the
general case is T times and over T is
greater than or equal to n and this
holds for all pay between one and n well
let's think of a simple application of
that if I choose the T that balances
anti chain size from change size then I
chose T to be the square root of n so
I'm over here I have square root of N
and here i have n divided by the square
root of n which is also square root of n
and what we can conclude is that every
end vertex tag has either a chain of
size at least the square root of n or an
anti chain of sighs at least square root
of n this turns out to actually have a
few applications but we're just going to
look at a fun application of this remark
that you have to have a chain or an anti
chain of sighs at least square root of n
you might have only one of these you
might have both but that one or the
other has to be at least as big a square
root of n let's think of a new deck that
I'm going to construct as follows I'm
going to draw an edge between students
in the class and I'm going to think of
one student as having a direct edge to
another student um if the first student
is both shorter and younger actually
meaning no taller than and no older than
the other let's just say shorter meaning
shorter or possibly the same height
younger or possibly the same age and so
the rule is that if I think of a student
as being represented by their shortness
s and their age a then a student with a
height s 1 and age
a one has a direct arrow to another
student with height s2 and age a to
providing that both that that the the
pair the first pair is less than or
equal to the second pair and both
coordinates s 1 is less than or equal to
s 2 and a 1 is less than or equal to a2
now we don't want ties here because that
would break the dag property if I have
two students with exactly the same age
and height so let's assume that we're
measuring age in microseconds and height
in in micrometers and with that kind of
finest the likelihood of a tie is pretty
low so then it becomes a dag again so
this is the definition of taking a dag
built out of pairs of there's a pure
degg for height and there's a pure dig
for age and I combined them into pairs
and I get a new deck by looking at how
the coordinates behave together this is
called the product reference a general
construction that comes up and we will
talk a little bit more about when we
re-examine dags in the context of the
language of relations and partial orders
anyway this is the product graph
according to dilworth lemma in a class
like ours of 141 students it means that
we're going to have a chain or an anti
chain in this product tag of size square
root of 141 rounded up or 12 so what
would in according to dilworth lemma in
this particular age height a graph what
does it mean for this to be an anti
chain suppose I take a bunch of students
and I line them up in order of size with
the bigger thought tallest on the left
and the shortest on the right if this is
going to be an anti chain it means that
they have to be getting older as they
get shorter because if I ever had a case
where somebody to the right was both
shorter and a younger than somebody to
the left it wouldn't be an anti chain
because they'd be comparable
so this is an it so an anti chain
according to dilworth lemma if you'd
sort the students by height they have to
be getting older as they get a shorter
if it was a chain they would be getting
younger as they got shorter but the more
interesting one is when they get is the
anti chained in this height birthday
example so we should be looking at what
will either have a chain or an anti
chain in this class according to this
product deck as a matter of fact we
really had an anti chain that here's a
quick list of a dozen students and
indeed um if you look at the birthdays
there's somebody who's 61 was born in
August 94 and then somebody who was born
in April 94 and his 60 all the way down
to somebody who was born in 1991 and
who's five feet tall so we looked out we
could have only had the chain but we
actually had the anti chain in this case